okay so i want to do one on avocado on toast
actually no that sounds like a joke but um i think
actually this is an important issue that people
need to understand alright so one thing that i've
realised recently and i'm sure people watching
would have seen this is a lot of newspapers
running articles that saying i gave up starbucks
and i gave up avocado on toast for three years
and then i bought this five hundred thousand pound
flat and the article was always like how i managed
to buy this £500,000 in London or howi
managed to be mortgage-free by the age of 35
this kind of thing like all stories about how
young people managed to be and get this amazing
property or manage to have their mortgage right
and it's always you know i really scrimped and
saved i gave up avocado on toast i stopped going
to starbucks i bought my own packed lunch to work
and then if you read these articles and
i promise you go and read through them
you will always see about two thirds of the way
down they just slipped in and then you know i used
that money plus 200 grand which i borrowed from
my mom and then i bought this property and it's
always like wait wait a minute wait a minute so
you stopped eating avocado toast and you and but
also you got 200 grand from your mom and i think
this is important for a couple of reasons firstly
because one thing that i see amongst my friendship
group right like i went to a grammar school and i
went to like elite universities so i know some
people from pretty well-off families but i also
know some people from families that are that
are poor or not well off right and what i see is
the kids from well our families buy properties
and they get a gift from their parents you know
it might be 50 grand it might be 150
grand they might be 250 grand right
because that's what you need to be able to buy
a property in london nowadays or in a lot of
cities you know what i mean a lot of australian
cities are even worse the amount of money you
need to get a deposit and um then my kids
from my kids my mates from poorer families
they see other people buying property and there's
no way they can do it because they can't get the
deposit they don't understand how are these guys
able to buy property and i'm not and the reason is
because increasingly the only way to get property
nowadays is to get massive gift from your parents
and people from poor families don't see that
so the first thing i want to do is open this up
because these newspapers give a misleading idea
that if you just worked a little harder you just
saved a little more you can get a property but
the reality if you look at these articles is it's
almost impossible in many places without a massive
gift from your parents so if there are people out
there who are watching feeling bad like i can't
afford property it's not what these articles are
saying the truth is realistically if you're from
the wrong family nowadays it's almost impossible
to get property that's the first thing but the
second thing is i think it highlights a little
bit something important about how economics and
media works right like i did an interview other day
and the person i was up against works for the IEA
institute of economic affairs sounds really fancy
right that's a think tank funded by billionaires
they pay people to go on the radio and say don't
tax billionaires that's what it is basically and
so much of the media is owned by billionaires
times owned by billionaires the sun owned by
billionaires talk radio owned by billionaires
the daily mail owned by billionaires right so all
of these newspapers and all these radio stations
sky news owned by billionaires they're
all owned by billionaires so obviously
they are going to send people out
there to say don't tax billionaires
and bear that in mind whenever you
see what these newspapers say but also
i think they want to give the impression that
things are okay as they are because at the moment
they don't want things to change but things are
working super well for the billionaires and at
the moment we have the situation in this country
and also in a lot of countries where for older
generations who own their own property things
look okay because the property prices have gone up
and i'll talk a lot about this in my video on
housing but for younger generations they're in
a situation where it's impossible for them to
purchase property and it's impossible to get
financial security and to save up the assets
you need to have a pension or to raise a family
but older people often don't see this and as
a result they vote for parties which are not
doing anything about supporting those people
but if they knew i think if a lot of older
people realized how difficult situation was the
younger generation they would vote against it but
the newspapers tell them oh it's okay as long as
they pull their socks up stop buying avocado toast
stop going to starbucks they'll be okay and get
property but the reality of it is increasingly
more and more families in this country and
then a lot of countries around the world
are unable to afford property and these newspapers
are giving a misleading idea like it's just a
problem of young people being silly but it's not
because house price the average house price in
london is like 600 grand now and the average
wage is like 30 grand you know you're gonna
have to stop buying coffee for what like 300 years
or something it's not going to happen right so um
yeah you know it's about avocado toast but it's
not about avocado toast it's about understanding
that very rich people spend a lot of money to
to give you these ideas about economics and
understanding that a lot of the economic
messages we receive are biased and often
they're designed to stop you from pushing back
because the system as it is is working really
really well for the super rich um and yeah you
know watching other videos where we talk about
inequality the ones we talk about how taxes are
being raised on working people are not on the rich
like why is that raising your taxes watch what
as well if i watch the housing video but um
understand that we've got a serious problem here
that will not get better unless we do something
and a lot of the people in power are not
incentivized to do it so if we want change
we're to have to make it happen
ourselves so yeah educate yourselves
watch my videos share the message
let's make things change
so it's intentionally designed national
insurance so that very rich people
pay a very low percent wealth inequality pushes
house prices up money printing pushes house prices
up so how's price go through the roof but at the
same time well through equality pushes wages down